if we just step back and look at our
the human species
what does slavery teach you about human
nature
the fact that slavery
uh
has appeared as a function of society
throughout human history there are two
possibilities
um
one is
it's
what people think they can do when god's
not watching
another is it's what they can do if they
think that god allows it
it's
really really well put
and uh
the fact that they want to do this kind
of subjugation what does that mean
well i mean it's pretty straightforward
in a way um
there are people who get to work for
free
there's economic in nature in some in
some sense yes but in order to do it i
mean almost always there are the diff
there are some examples in the ancient
world where this wasn't the case but
almost always it had to be subjugated
people or people regarded as different
one of the things actually i've tried to
sort of inject into the
discussion through this book among other
things is
is a recognition that
there was there were very major
questions still going on in the 18th and
early 19th century the one resolved
which were one of the
reasons why slavery was not as morally
repugnant to people then as it was to us
now as it is to us now and that's the
question of polygenesis and monogenesis
um
at the time of thomas jefferson the
founding fathers were were thinking and
working
they didn't know
because nobody knew
whether the human races were related or
not
um
the there was there were arguments the
monogenesis argument that that we were
all indeed from the same racial stark
apologies this argument was that we
weren't we were
you know black africans ethiopians
and they're often referred to at the
time
um
because they provided some of the first
slaves
were different from white europeans
simply not related in any way
and that makes it easier of course that
makes it easier to enslave people if you
think they're not your brother
am i my brother's keeper no he's not
your brother
uh
and
there's
it's it's a it's a very
it was a very troubling argument in the
in the 18th and 19th century also
because there was a biblical question it
threw up it threw up a theological
question which was i
mean and
people were literally debating this at
the time
um
was there also a black adam and eve
was there there were an indian adam and
eve the native american adam and eve
i mean this was a serious theological
debate
because they didn't know the answer and
it i mean people say that darwin
um
solved this it wasn't just darwin of
course but
by the late 19th century the argument
that we were not
all related
as human beings had suffered so many
blows that
you had to really be very very ignorant
deliberately willfully ignorant to
ignore it by that so it no longer was
after darwin a theological question it
became a moral question it was already a
moral question but it clarified darwin
clarifies it definitely and then you're
in the same in a situation of you're not
subjugating some other people you're
subjugating your own kin
and
that becomes morally unsustainable
you